Wesley Johnson with the field goal a  fast-paced star  [Applause]  [Music]  get counts of a foul loosen the bolts on  the rim I may have been clean there  madam I've been cleaned and then the  handling into the net we know this is to  Tokyo us girl nice belt  [Applause]  [Music]  looking at a North Carolina State 27  years old played four years in NC  in LA and the Clippers have a shoot  point lead on the Thunder home beautiful  pass  let's get open late in that cut usually  below the second hash  Paul George heads that way now  [Applause]  Oh George  so the game tied at 91 it was tied at 91  Russell Westbrook was a shock for felt  widow  [Applause]  Wow  so he's gonna chase it down spotty  Felton looked at